blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman as we continue to follow the
absolute
tragedy that is taking place in texas
with power outages
people without hot water people without
heat people struggling to get food
we talked yesterday about republican
texas governor ted cruz
flying off to cancun with his family to
hit the beach that was
ted cruz's approach beto o'rourke former
democratic senate candidate and
presidential candidate
um decided instead
to phone bank and call elderly folks to
see if they were okay but he also is
making some very appropriate and very
harsh comments about
texas leadership actually going as far
to say that texas is approaching failed
state
status beto o'rourke said first of all
so much of this was avoidable going back
to the deregulation of our electric grid
here in texas which has actually created
an incentive to not weatherize or
protect against these events
better o'rourke absolutely right as
we've told you before in 2011 texas had
power outage issues
an extensive report was compiled saying
do these things to protect yourselves in
the future
they weren't done and it happened again
absolute negligence by republican
leaders in texas
but then better or going further and
saying the energy capital of north
america
cannot provide enough energy to warm and
power people's homes
we are nearing a failed state in texas
and it has nothing to do with god or
natural disasters
it has everything to do with those in
positions of public trust
who have failed us people have died
in texas and tens of thousands are still
in the dark and cold
and you would think maybe they'll change
their tune on going it alone
and separating from federally managed
power grids
maybe they would change their tune on
climate change doesn't
really mean anything because as climate
science predicts
you have erratically hot and erratically
cold weather events
that are part of a broader shift in
climate often to the warmer but that
doesn't mean you don't have outrageously
cold or erratic snowstorms
in places that don't typically have them
and of course
if you try to bring that up texas
republicans will now
hide behind that tired old trope
this is not the time to politicize
a tragedy is what they will say well it
also wasn't the time to politicize it
in 2011 when this happened and you got a
report saying hey here's what you should
do
and you did nothing about it so i'm glad
that beto o'rourke is saying these
things
i worry however that he is sort of
yelling into the void
because there are so many republican
texas officials ted cruz
former governor rick perry current
governor greg abbott
lieutenant governor dan patrick these
people don't seem willing or
remotely interested in seeing reason
let's hope
let's hope that by monday we have better
news about the circumstances
for uh tens of thousands if not hundreds
of thousands or even at the sort of top
top level millions of texans that have
been affected by this
uh okay there was a complete total
softball pandering brown nosing
interview that donald trump did
on fox news with sean hannity on
thursday night let's look at some clips
we'll jump right into it the sort of
framework here
was donald trump doing a media tour
because of the death of radical
right-wing radio host rush limbaugh
reminder rush limbaugh
celebrated the death of ruth bader
ginsburg
celebrated the deaths of aids victims in
the 90s
not a good guy trump calling in and
hannity starts in with you know
mr president sir it was such a great
idea to give rush limbaugh the
presidential medal of freedom how did
you come up
with such a great idea total suck-up
let's take a listen
a true original joining us now on the
phone is
president donald trump mr president i
know that the honor
of his life came from you
and what that medal of freedom meant to
him
i know the behind the scenes story i
know i know
who made the first call to me anyway was
matt drudge and and
jared kushner and um and i know you made
your decision and
with melania there in about five seconds
and you said that's a great idea
tell us about it well it was an idea
that
we had that a lot of people suggested to
me frankly a lot of great
people of our country largely
republicans it was an amazing night
because the republicans
went wild and the democrats sat there
but they all respected
rush and i think it was you know one of
the
great honors of his life presidential
medal of freedom
it's a big deal and he uh he was very
honored by it
and he was a great gentleman just like
mark said i i listened to mark and
you know mark is so terrific but you
know he said he's special
and rush was really special he was a
very special guy
you've said irreplaceable and it's true
he's irreplaceable
again trump deciding that the thing
he gave rush was the thing
rush was the most honored by trump needs
that to be true
for his own narcissism and he keeps
repeating that the right
loves rush and the left respected rush
i don't know anyone on the left that
respected rush limbaugh
i don't know anyone on the left who
would have respect for people who
celebrate the deaths
of people with aids or celebrate the
death of ruth bader ginsburg these
aren't mere political differences about
what the tax rate should be
where you say hey you know what we
disagree but i respect their point of
view
cheering aids deaths has nothing
respectable about it it is a bizarre
thing for donald trump to keep repeating
then hannity goes into even more sucking
up to trump
and trump again reveals that the thing
he really likes about rush
is that he supported trump that's all
trump cares about
you know this this side of you that i
know a lot of americans don't know
and i know many people that this story
holds true for
and i know in the case of rush and when
rush had his diagnosis
a little over a year ago i knew you were
calling him regularly
minimum of once a month often much more
than that
and you would always be checking in with
how are you feeling how are the
treatments how's everything going
and on i know you talked to them a lot
what were those conversations like
well it was interesting because i didn't
know rush at all as you know i didn't
know him at all
until i had gotten word that from
somebody that rush was with us all the
way he was
you know we have this guy who was so big
on radio i
i knew a lot about rush but i didn't
know him
and he was with me all the way and it
was sort of incredible i got to know him
after that
and uh he was much different actually
you know when you were
he was a very very um
i wouldn't say not outgoing but he was
very very warm he was just a very warm
person and and you know when people got
to know him
i loved playing golf with russian i said
i used to call him the bull because he
was actually a very strong guy
physically very strong guy
he hit the ball a long way when he hit
it he went a long way and
uh but you got to know him and and he
and he loved this country and he loved
his wife
all the things trump says about rush his
ratings
his ability to do a radio show all that
stuff it would all be equally true
even if rush didn't support trump but
you and i know
that if rush was an anti-trump
republican who died
donald trump would not be doing this
donald trump doesn't have friends the
only thing that matters to trump is
are you a brown-nosing sycophant if so
i'll call you a friend
until you say the wrong thing and then i
say your you know uh
what's that lightweight as he often says
what you do
what you do for me and what you've done
lately is all that matters to donald
trump
let's look at a little bit more of this
here is sean hannity
with just a stunning brown nosing of
trump saying uh hey
here were russia's top issues these are
your issues as well
sir mr president trump on russia's show
today
i was listening um before i began my
radio program and
they played a segment of rush and in
that segment he said
if you took tapes of him when he started
in 1988 and syndication again nobody
thought that
that anyone can syndicate during the
daytime and be successful and
and he proved all the naysayers wrong
and if you look at where he stood
conservative justices liberty freedom
less government intrusion intrusion
less regulation less taxes lower taxes
energy independence secure borders uh
choice in schools the second amendment
free and fair trade
peace through strength sound familiar
because that's your agenda that's what
you did he was right there
he understood it he got it and he's been
that way for a long time you know he
hasn't been somebody that's changed he
didn't go
from being a liberal to being a
conservative i mean he was there from
the beginning and uh he hasn't changed
his views hadn't changed very much
and his audience as you know better than
probably anybody the loyalty of his
audience was just incredibly
staggering it's actually interesting and
sad how never changing your views is
seen as a badge of honor in some circles
on the right and on the left and as i've
said many times
having the exact same views for 50 years
likely means you're not learning
anything now i want to be really clear
i don't mean it's typical for say a 40
year old
not talking about anyone in particular
for a 40 year old
to have a complete political awakening
and 180 degree reversal where all of a
sudden they denounce everything they
stood for for 40 years
and say i was wrong all along and i'm
actually a right-wing nut okay
that raises red flags and it suggests to
me grifting
but what i'm talking about is saying
your views haven't changed at all
for 40 50 years as if it's a badge of
honor
look at how much we've learned about
life and humanity and the planet
in 50 years how could your views not
change
over that period of time even my views
on many issues
are modified and adjusted and updated to
account for new things that we know
it's sad and it doesn't bode well for
the country
to see that praised as a badge of honor
just one more clip here hannity
explaining what might have been so
damaging to kaylee mcinanny listen to
this
your own kaylee mcinerney i mentioned
earlier tweeted that you know she was a
rushed baby your dad would be
listening in the car and it and it
shaped
her viewpoint to conservatism
uh and he did that for so many of us and
so many around the country
um i i want to thank you um
i appreciate you being on the program i
know i i read your statement the other
day and i know
you said in the in the months ahead you
have a lot you want to tell us and
we won't do it tonight obviously but
when that when that time comes we're
looking forward to hearing
what your future plans are and um
what you are planning to do uh i have a
funny feeling
we're going to hear a lot more from
donald trump are my instincts correct
there's a lot to talk about and uh our
country is a great place and
we're going to make it even greater as
the expression goes but
we have a lot to talk about but today's
all about rush
don't you think and so hannity mentions
there that
growing up as a little kid kaylee
mcinanny trump's former press secretary
would have rushed limbaugh playing in
the background because that's what her
dad listened to
you know that explains so much and that
is a cautionary tale
not to have radical right-wing radio
playing in the background
when you're trying to raise
well-adjusted kids a real lesson in
parenting there
so trump back on fox news there it is
we'll see what role trump plays or
doesn't play in the republican party
going forward
and you can let me know your thoughts
about trump's return to the airwaves
i'm on twitter at deepakman the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right let's talk to some folks from
the audience
to hear what is on folks minds another
very busy week of news with more
upcoming and many different things going
on including great news on
uh vaccinations covid cases declining
but still
many challenges ahead and so many
different things going on we will do it
via
discord as we have been doing for
several months and it is working
it's working well i would say
davidpakman.com
discord let's go first to anna
from vietnam anna from vietnam you're on
the air
oh hello yes how are you oh my god i'm
so
i'm sorry i'm getting so nervous oh
please don't be nervous how are you
i'm nervous because we've never had a
caller from vietnam before
yeah i'm nervous because this is the
first time i've ever made a call to
anyone kind of famous before oh i was
i thought you were going to say this is
the first time you've ever spoken to
anyone via digital means i was going to
be surprised
yeah that that that'd be odd so what's
going on what uh what can i do for you
anna
um but yeah i have like heard and i've
seen like in some
social medias that are there's been an
uprising
racism against asian people in the us
yes so i want to know if you acknowledge
that and i want to know what are your
thoughts about it
i guess yeah i i believe that i mean
listen i have no personal
i follow the science and the data
and a number of uh well-respected
um organizations that track hate
incidents have seen
that since the start of the pandemic in
the united states there have been
significantly larger numbers of
hate incidents against asian folks
believed anna to be because donald trump
kept talking about
china china china the china virus the
kung flu
etc etc so i think that
um i mean my view is that it's
disgusting and it's despicable
and that we should be able to
simultaneously say
china's not being transparent we have a
diplomatic problem with china
without fomenting random
attacks on asian people in the street
you know these are two different things
it's disgusting
yeah i understand and uh yeah i just
want to make sure that
we are not like being super conflicting
on this i know that is not like the best
source
to get your information from like from
just social media
in general because i have heard a lot of
people like having
um like actual thoughts about it
via like science stuff and paperwork and
things like that
but to be able to like have it so
obvious that even
the sources that are not supposed to
give you like specific
and very accurate information about it
like
talking about it is quite huge you know
and um
to me the america has always been a
place where you can
be free and uh kind of like achieve your
american dream so
to see that happen to my people is very
upsetting and very
unsettling in a way i completely agree
with you and
and understand how how horrible that
must be anna you speak
beautiful english how would tell us
about how did you learn english in
school in vietnam
oh thank you
oh i'm sorry um so this
[Music]
because yeah i formulated my thoughts
before calling oh okay
but i'm getting like nervous laughs
every day no you're doing great
you're doing great anna listen i wish my
american callers took a moment to
formulate their thoughts before they
called
they could really take a lesson from you
my pleasure anna thank you anna from
vietnam
uh as close to a perfect phone call
as i can imagine let's go next to jared
from new york
jared you're on the air
hey david um i know you've interviewed
ken
jennings in the past which was real cool
yes
for people who don't know the many many
time winner of jeopardy
yes i was wondering if um you've seen
any of the new episodes where he's taken
over as host
um and if you have any thoughts on kind
of how he's done or
what they're going to be doing what
they're going to be bringing on guest
hosts so i just wonder if you had any
thoughts on that no
i haven't seen an episode of jeopardy in
probably a decade
and i haven't watched a live tv show as
it's airing
other than sports or news for almost as
long so i have no i i didn't even know
he was hosting jeopardy to be quite
honest
yeah he he took over on an interim basis
and it's interesting it's tough because
it's
it's hard to kind of get used to his
style after seeing outs for so long but
yeah yeah that's all i just wanted to
get your thoughts are you like a bit
i know that jeopardy fans are very
adamant like they they
they watch every episode is has this
been a huge
thing in the jeopardy community oh yeah
it's been a very big thing um it's just
there's a lot of discussions
of is it is people find it a little odd
but
is it because they're not used to it is
it because he's just new and he'd have
to get more comfortable or
is it because he's just not you know a
great host interesting
so everybody and the guests coming up
are interesting it's people like
anderson cooper will be guest hosting
and katie couric but then you have like
aaron rodgers who's an nfl quarterback
so they're they're taking an interesting
approach
i would like to guest host maybe we can
get a campaign going i would be
interested in doing that
that would be really cool for sure all
right well let's uh let's make it happen
it sounds like you're kind of an insider
in this community i think you have the
power
absolutely absolutely all right okay
thanks jared from new york and i'm not
kidding i expect to hear from you about
guest hosting let's go next to kate from
denmark
denmark one of my favorite countries
kate you're on the air
kate from denmark please unmute yourself
you are on the air but
you do need to understand sorry um
hello hi it's been a while since i've
listened
to so because i've been busy so i'm a
little behind
the news but i
heard that a new bill is
perhaps maybe being passed that will be
making it easier to restore so to vote
in america
how have you heard about that one no i
haven't is this a
this is a federal bill for what
automatic voter registration i know of
states that are doing this but i've not
heard of the bill you're talking about
kate
um something familiar to to it
it was supposed to make it easier also
um what was it there was another thing
in the bill
is something like if you donate a
certain amount of small
um representatives it will
be matched up so if you
donate i think it was 10 or in
dollars it will be 217 at least it'll be
it would be easier for smaller people
like democrats or black people and such
to actually have a chance instead of
just the big
representatives smaller people like
democrats or black people kate i've got
to tell you i don't know what you're
talking about but i will look into it i
can tell you that
yeah i just heard i'm not sure if it was
something solid but a
friend of mine mentioned that they heard
it on another new show
um all right i will look into that i
will look into that
how are things in denmark by the way
uh there are currently
as well as they can be we just had a
snowstorm recently
okay uh but if it's corona
wise we're still on lockdown and it
looks like
it might be extended i see
and are you in are you in copenhagen or
are you elsewhere in the country
uh no i am in the [ __ ] and called uh
fiasco
did you say it's a car it's a commune
yeah um it is instead of state
it's called kumuna in denmark
ah okay but it it is a commune am i
understanding that correctly
yeah and
and do you how is that do you like that
oh it's basically like a state like
denmark is
separate up in different uh
communes so the budget is easier to
handle because some
of farming lands and others are more
like big
cities like alba so they need different
things
oh i see i think we're talking about so
you're not saying what i understand as a
commune is something else
okay i understand i understand yeah um
okay good well i
listen kate i appreciate the call i hope
to get back to denmark
as soon as it's safe yeah that would be
lovely have a nice
evening all right you too kate from
denmark
um great to hear from her
let's go next to preston
from birmingham now is this birmingham
alabama or united kingdom
preston from birmingham hi can you hear
me david yes i can it sounds like it's
alabama
not not uh uk yeah you can tell no
accent
that was i was immediately able to
deduce that
all right david well i took the time to
formalize my thoughts for this question
oh thank you
um i went ahead and wrote a thesis for
you that i'll submit for you to review
thank you so i have a few questions
regarding bernie sanders uh
raise the wage act sure um
so the raise the wage act would add to
25 to the federal minimum wage
every year through 2025 right um
after that the wage would be increased
by the annual percentage
increase of the median hourly wage of
all employees
yes um so my first question about this
is um why are they deciding to increase
the wage by the annual percentage
increase
of the median hourly wage as opposed to
something like adjusting for inflation
um
and also why are they um specifically
excluding
uh annual percentage increases in
salaries from that calculation
well i think that the there's a bunch of
different stuff there first of all
um when we talk about the hourly wage
you're talking about the wage for people
paid
hourly so it is logical to me that you
wouldn't
index it to salaried folks who might
work 35
or 60 hours per week that part makes
sense so maybe we can take that piece
off the table i think
you would look at you would if you're
going to index an hourly wage you would
look at hourly workers is that
fair yes okay in terms of doing it to
median
rather than inflation i don't know the
answer i've not i've not read about the
reason
the reason to do it median rather than
mean
uh seems obvious and and as people have
given this example before if you put a
hundred people in a room and one of them
is bill gates
the mean wage will be really high but
the median
may not be uh because so so median
rather than mean makes sense but as far
as versus inflation i've seen a lot of
proposals that would index the minimum
wage to inflation i don't know why it's
being done
to the median hourly wage but i would be
interested in learning why
i would too um i completely agree with
everything you're saying though
makes sense um i've got one more
question for you about this
sure um so sanders is proposing that 225
increase every year through 2025.
um what's your opinion on this
time frame of the rollout do you think
it would be faster
to or it would be better to increase
this wage faster
maybe as a way to uh benefit low wage
earners and allow them to put
money back into the local economy during
the pandemic
and on the other hand i understand that
small businesses would be hurt
by sudden wage increases as was
addressed in the town hall last night
yeah um so what's your opinion on this
time frame do you think this is a
realistic goal do you think it should go
faster
slower so i would love for it to go
faster but i recognize that it's
extraordinarily unlikely to be
politically viable and when you look at
senators like
kirsten cinema and joe manchin who
aren't even sure they
they want a 15 minimum wage the idea of
making it a 15
federal minimum wage tomorrow just seems
so unlikely so i'm not surprised that
they're looking at phasing it in over
time now of course
by 2025 a 15 dollar minimum wage
is going to be a lot less than it would
be today because of inflation not a lot
less i mean the u.s has relatively
low inflation but it's already going to
be time to look at the
the next step at that point in time but
i'm not surprised because particularly
in places where the state minimum a lot
of states already have minimum wages of
10 11 12 14
even in places where they the state
minimum wage really is
in still in the sevens you're talking
about more than doubling it
and whatever you believe the minimum
wage ultimately should be
and i believe it should be much higher
doubling the minimum wage
will have an economic impact and so i'm
not surprised at all that it would be
phased in over time and uh if bernie is
behind it i think that he's he's thought
it out well
yeah i agree david thank you for the
time uh taking time to answer my
questions hope you have a good day
you too all right very good great to
hear from from our friends
in alabama as always let's go next
to cali from wisconsin cali from
wisconsin you're on the air
hi how's it going hi how are you good
how are you
doing well um to be honest i don't
really have much of a question i was
just wanting to listen in and i don't
know how to operate discords
oh my goodness well tell me this what
how are thing
you guys in wisconsin you have wind
power and it gets really cold right
we do and it does and it seems that
everything's been winterized
and there's no problems oh we uh
we don't have any issues with that
really only times that we lose power is
i mean as would anyone with a really big
storm and stuff like that but nothing
associated with
or no no wisconsin wyoming montana you
know a lot of these places are
counter points to the claim that the
problem in texas
is wind power you know that it's not
cali and that's uh that's all that's all
really
really great and otherwise things are
okay yeah things are fine no i do want
to
say i feel i mean there's a lot of
people making
jokes on social media and it's kind of
easy too because we get that amount of
snow and
you know that temperature all the damn
time but yeah i mean i just want to make
the point to
you know people that you i mean and i
mean obviously i'm you know preaching
the choir you know this these people are
not prepared for this kind of stuff at
all and
they don't even have the consensus to
deal with it to no fault of their own
um so i don't know i'm just terrified
for those people i'm in a lot of uh
plant groups on facebook and a lot of
them are um
just pretty much sacrificing all of
their plants because right houses
their houses are 30 degrees right now
you know i have to evacuate and go
somewhere else and
i mean that's the least of their
problems but yeah it's not the people's
fault in texas it's it's i mean listen
they had a report a decade ago that said
hey here's how to prevent this from
happening again because it happened in
2011
and they just didn't do it exactly
exactly things that would be so
common sense to us but hey what um what
growing zone are you in in wisconsin
um i think we'd be five
oh okay that's tough for winter right i
mean you can't grow much in winter
no i have um i mean even during the
summer i have
all my plants inside it's only a couple
months that they can be outside anyway
but
definitely need a supplement we have so
overcast here
what's your best producing fruit or
vegetable
um i don't do i do i have house plants
oh oh so you're not growing that you're
not doing oh wow that's sad that i would
like to see you get into maybe tomatoes
or something
i actually did just grow some tomatoes
oh come seed actually
yeah i'm getting those ready for spring
but beautiful anyway i'll
go talk to more interesting people
thanks callie kelly from
what's more interesting than tomatoes i
mean there could be there could be
nothing more interesting
than that all right let's take a quick
break if you're holding don't hang up
because we're going right back to the
phones after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's join
pakman.com if the normal prices strike
you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
all right let's hear from a few more
people via discord at davidpakman.com
discord we'll go next to jen from
providence jen you're on the air
hey can you hear me yes i can hi uh
we've actually spoken a couple of times
before
uh i live on the border beautiful oh yes
oh you're right right right and did you
work in massachusetts was it
yeah i'll work in mass shop and mass but
then you live in providence you go back
and forth
and uh you see my super chats all the
time my screen name's fair queen
oh okay beautiful yeah so i actually
wanted to talk to you about the uh super
chat i did earlier to get your opinion
on it
uh it was on a wjar your local station
too so you'll probably end up seeing it
um there's a grocery store chain in the
northwest
called fred meyers okay they lost power
and they had a lot of food waste
so they were actually instructing their
employees to destroy as much as they
could so the homeless wouldn't go and
take the food
um people started taking some anyway and
also people running local food banks
because their supplies are so short
yes uh the guy actually had a dozen uh
portland police officers
go and stand guard and threaten people
to like not be able to take any of this
food yeah
um it's gotten that bad with the
corporatism and the
girl who did the article said this was a
guy who also refused to donate
their old computers to local schools
as you describe it and nothing else and
of course i'm just going by what you're
telling me
it sounds absolutely depraved and
disgusting now we've covered in the past
how
many grocery stores are hesitant to
donate
food that is maybe on the verge of
expiration to food banks because of
concerns about liability
which are not their fault and even that
i sort of take
issue with like can't we figure out some
way of making sure that that we can do
that because food wastage is such an
issue and we want to
deal with that liability it doesn't
sound at all from what you're telling me
like that's what's at issue here and if
if it's as you describe and again i
don't know um
it's disgusting yeah that's why you have
better sources than i do so i was hoping
that maybe you could do a little
research
and before tonight's show maybe look
into that well you know
the uh the show has already been the
show has been produced for today but i
will look into it i do want to know more
about it it sounds crazy
and uh real quick uh so all this stuff
that they're saying about the solar
panels being covered in snow and whatnot
they're trying to blame green energy
yeah
my fiancee is union electrician and
build solar farms as part of his job
they these panels are specially equipped
to not allow snow to stay built up on
them
right they're put at a specific angle
they're coated with special uh
like kind of like a waxy kind of thing
almost yep so
that is not the problem even though
you're saying oh we're not winterized or
whatever
i mean i grew up in louisiana if you get
a dusting of snow it's the apocalypse
right
but yeah still they cannot blame
these solar panels because they are so
well engineered to handle this
yeah the solar panel piece i'm less
familiar with i know that the
that it is that with when it comes to
the wind turbines
they simply haven't made the changes to
them that you can make in order to make
them
uh impervious to the cold weather like
they've done in montana and wyoming and
wisconsin and so many other places
you want to hear something funny sure uh
they set
up a couple of wind turbines in one of
the nearby towns of johnston rhode
island
and there were people living in this
apartment complex that complained it was
going to
blow the smell of the city landfill
towards their apartment complex
oh boy i can't imagine that that's the
case given the at the elevation the
height at which you put the wind
turbines
i've never heard that even alleged
before well just everybody was sharing
the clip from futurama him saying
windmills do not work that way
right but yeah i'm actually thinking it
was going to blow the smell other than
the wind moving the turbine i hadn't
heard that but i will check it out
all right thank you so much david uh you
know you keep seeing my super chats i
watch the show every day
all right jen from providence great to
hear from you very much appreciate that
let's go next to scipio from california
scipio from california you're on the air
scipio family in california you're on
the air hey david can you hear me yes i
can
hey this is so cool i'm a long time
listener but first time caller
thank you um i wanted to ask uh
we're like a year into coven 19
impacting the us
and there's still people that just won't
take the guidelines seriously at all
like just this week i
had to go inside an office and i didn't
see one person wearing a mask
and right i i don't like know
at this point like what can you do to
try and
convince those people it's as serious as
it is because i try to share information
and
citations with friends and family and on
my social media but it just seems like
i'm
screaming into the void so i just wanted
to get your thoughts sadly at this point
at this point i don't know that there is
much to do and you know unfortunately
let me let me back up fortunately cases
are going down
vaccination is increasing and and
hopefully
over the next four to six months we are
going to see a dramatic change to the
circumstances
um coronavirus may become seasonal sort
of like the flu
uh whatever things are going to improve
most of those people who have not been
paying attention to the guidelines all
along
they may be responsible for the deaths
of others most of them of course will
survive
and they will be re they will see their
actions reinforced because they'll say
look we got through it i never wore a
mask i did whatever the hell i wanted if
i got it it wasn't that bad
for me and unfortunately we're sort of
at the point where i think they're
beyond reach
and they will benefit from vaccination
just as much as everybody who's been
well behaved will benefit
it will reinforce their belief that it
wasn't that bad
ever and i don't know there's much that
we can do about it
yeah that's unfortunately the conclusion
yeah
i've sort of arrived at as well but uh
yeah i'm glad it's we're at least seeing
the light at the end of the tunnel
now are are the bosses not enforcing is
there not a mask policy or is there one
but it's not enforced
um at the places that i've been to
like the person who's sort of running
the office
like they've been there and they've also
been uh without a mask
oh i said um and like
yeah i've seen it where the people who
would be in charge of whatever that
context is like they're also not wearing
a mask
it's like a work culture thing got it
got it got it yeah i mean uh
it's it's happening in many parts of the
country more in some than others
and eventually they're all going to get
bailed the ones that survive
um which of course statistically will be
most of them will will sort of be bailed
out by vaccines
yeah yeah i didn't know if you uh i know
a lot of people have been talking about
the
um snowstorm but i don't know if you saw
that bloomberg
interviewed dan woodfin he's a senior
director for electric
reliability council of texas and he even
came out and said like
this nonsense about wind turbines is
just that it's nonsense and he
sort of breaks down like how much energy
it makes up and how it doesn't make
sense that
people are blaming like wind turbines
and clean energy for what's going on i
didn't
see that but certainly i've read similar
analyses and it's very clear that the
problem here is not wind turbines yeah
yeah anyways thanks for taking my call
david all right thanks very much
there's scipio from california great to
hear from you
um let's see where are we going to go
next there's a lot of very interesting
people wanting to get on
let's go to darren from the united
kingdom darren from the uk you're on the
air
david yes great program thank you
so um i have a lighthearted question for
you all right so
when netflix make insurrection the tv
show
who would you cast as uh trump mcconnell
and giuliani oh wow i have no idea
trump mcconnell and julie i don't know i
mean maybe trump it would be alec
baldwin i think the the real question is
who will cast who will be cast as me and
um i think i would like it to be joseph
gordon levitt if i'm totally honest with
you
great cool a lovely show keep the faith
okay thank you very much a very very
powerful question if anybody knows
joseph gordon levitt let's see if we can
make that happen i would like it
uh if he portrayed me that would be
really good
let's go next to justin from orange
county california
justin from orange county hi yes i can
hi david i was just wondering uh what
your thoughts were on joe biden's town
hall yesterday
and saying that he wasn't planning on
canceling the 50 000
in student debt yeah so i i we we talked
about this a little bit on a live stream
earlier this week
i i appreciated that he was just being
direct in his answer
biden never ran on canceling 50 000 in
student debt
he's not pretending like he's going to
and he just said i'm i'm not going to do
it now some of the
some of the reasoning he gave uh about
well we want to do k through 12 stuff or
this or that i mean you can walk and
chew gum at the same time if he was
determined to cancel 50k
and do k-12 funding and improvements i
think he would be able to do it so i
think that
some of the reasoning after the fact
wasn't wasn't great
but i i was refreshed as i said before
you you know if trump were to be asked
will you do 50k
trump would say well you know we're
thinking about a lot of different things
but you've got to remember that college
has really become
indoctrination and for a lot of people
they go to college they come out and all
of a sudden they believe all these
horrible things like
crying chuck and crazy nancy are good
people and we gotta vote for crazy
bernie
so i'm not so big on college necessarily
although i went to u-pen and got the
best grades and you know i
i did so great at the top school and my
kids went there but you know ten
thousand twenty thousand fifty 000 these
are numbers and we're looking at them
very strongly and
we'll come back to that in some period
of time like that would be trump's
answer
right biden said yeah no i'm not going
to do the 50k
and that's direct it's consistent with
what he said all along he's not
bamboozling anybody
so i appreciated the directness the
honesty i wish his policy were a
different one
so you stand behind the cancellation
personally
i don't know about full cancellation i
have my doubts about full cancellation
of all student debt i do think that um
the the reason i'm more partial to
partial would be that we have a
situation where
sure college is optional but
increasingly with more and more jobs
requiring college
and the cost of college going up and up
and up
it's it's not totally clean to me just
to say
if you choose to go to college then you
should you know just that's it you've
chosen and you should be responsible for
the full debt
at the same time to say everybody
just gets a full cancellation of all
student debt
i'm not there so i'm for a partial
cancellation
and i've seen a number of different
plans that would structure it in
different ways
um i don't know exactly whether i would
put a dollar amount on it or a
percentage or how i would do it
okay that makes sense thank you david
all right my pleasure a lot of
meaty substantive questions
coming in today let's see who we want to
talk to next
how about a read from milwaukee
read from milwaukee you're on the air
hey david how are you
i'm doing well um so i've actually got
uh some constructive criticism for you
beautiful um
so this has to go back to uh
something that you said about i forget
it was a fox interview about
china uh fighting about how they
were how biden wouldn't respond to
um yeah let me let me explain it so the
the the clip was correct me if i'm wrong
um that someone someone uh alleged
that if china nuked us biden would do
nothing
yeah yeah um i
i i think the way that you said that
like you you said
if china nuked us you know when they
talk about nuclear aggression
um generally that means like
you know just showing steps of you know
nuclear tests
stuff like that at least that's my
opinion
um i and i think sometimes you you get a
little hyperbolic with stuff
okay uh specifically in that case um
yeah anyway so just thought i would uh
share that
all right
was that it yeah oh okay all right thank
you very much
yeah no i think um i mean listen i i
responded to it as i saw it i saw it as
it was being
alleged that joe biden is so weak on
china he would let them nuke us and
wouldn't even do anything and obviously
i thought that that was a ridiculous
assertion to make but i'll review the
video again
thank you all right very good thank you
for the call that's going to do it for
today
i'm sorry i wasn't able to talk to
everybody but we did talk to lots of
interesting people
we'll take a quick break and we will
take calls again in the future
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media
and you can contribute any amount you
want on patreon as little as one dollar
per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
slash david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right let's get into audience
questions for the week first one david
what do you think the impact is of
donald trump's acquittal at his second
impeachment this is this is a good
question you know there were tons of hot
takes after trump was
acquitted for the second time last
saturday
about now what what is the impact and
there were some articles saying
trump is acquitted but weakened and
others saying trump is revitalized
i think that all of those takes are
basically bs in the sense that
the acquittal was a foregone conclusion
all along we knew that there
were not going to be 17 republican
senators willing to vote to convict
convict witnesses or no witnesses
evidence or no evidence you could have a
signed letter from trump saying
i deliberately incited the riot and
planned to do it all along
and they still would have acquitted
donald trump so i don't think the
conviction or acquittal itself
if it had been a conviction it'd be
different i don't think the acquittal
itself
really changes that much i think it's
too
soon to say what the now
post-second impeachment trumpian
movement
is is uh going to do or the direction
it's going to go because we're really in
uncharted territory here
trump has said he wants to stay in
politics
trump has talked about will be back
rumors about a 2024
run it might happen it might not happen
trump could just be totally bored with
politics by then
trump might just be exhausted he may
feel like he's too old for i mean just
who knows it's really really difficult
to know
but the most interesting aspect of the
acquittal
for the immediate is how does it impact
republicans in 2021 gubernatorial races
and how does it impact republicans in
2022
the people who voted to acquit
uh and the people in the house who so
some of the senators who voted to acquit
and everybody in the house who voted not
to impeach
has an election in 2022 and that's still
a long time
the american political memory
is quite short in many ways um
but it will be a real question as to
whether there are repercussions to those
who were on what i would argue is
obviously the wrong side
when it comes to impeachment will
republican voters hold them accountable
or not
most republican voters for now seem to
be very much behind trump so there may
there may be no accountability and you
could see in 2022
the most trumpian brown nosers people
uh in the senate but also the real
sycophants who are only here because of
trump in the house like
marjorie taylor greene madison cawthorne
lauren bobert and some others if they
get re-elected
in 2022 which is still a ways from now
but the campaigns are starting in the
next seven eight months
unbelievably if they get re-elected it
is a real
sign that that faction has won out in
the republican party
and then what happens in terms of a
possible split we talked last
friday i think it was about a hundred
former republican officials
many from the bush era some from trump
others who
are saying we're leaving the republican
party and we're going to start a
traditional conservative party
if the trumpian wing is cemented as the
wing
sort of like when we talk about the
virus you've got the main variant and
then what else you've got these other
variants
but then those other variants can take
over and become the dominant variants if
trumpian
uh politics becomes the dominant
republican strain
you may see traditional republicans
split off at the same time the reverse
could happen
you could see a rejection of these green
bobert cawthorn types
and maybe they will end up splitting off
what seems
very clear to me is that at least as of
right now
if trump wants the nomination in 2024
it is essentially his for the taking we
have new
polling that tells us about that and
we're going to talk about that
in an upcoming segment one other thing
to think about as far as trump goes is
that historically voters don't like
losers
trump has lost and he has shed some
support
among republican voters he still has a
lot of support but he has
lost some of it the people that stay
are more likely to be the real die-hard
radicals
and if you see that willingness to
follow trump elsewhere which right now
is at 64 percent of republicans if it
drops to 50
if it drops to 40 if it drops to 30 by
2022
that is going to dramatically change
what's possible
in terms of upcoming elections for
donald trump
and that's actually the next question so
let's go right into that
another question i got was what do
republicans do
if donald trump runs in 2024
based on the numbers right now with
trump leading a 2024
primary poll republicans do nothing it
this
as of right now this is donald trump's
for the taking
now of course depending on what happens
in 2022
and depending on what happens with
polling around trump versus non-trump
republicans
beyond 2022 things could change but
right now
donald trump in a recent poll of 2024
primary voters trump has 53 percent
support
second place is pence with 12 percent
support
third place is don jr with
i think it was somewhere around six
percent support
so this is a difficult position to be in
if you are a
a non-trump republican because based on
the math right now
the 2024 nomination is trump's
if he wants it he will be 78 years old
at the time
it's unclear what criminal or civil
issues he will have in the state of
georgia in the state of new york
who knows four years is a very very long
time
but what do republicans do if trump runs
in 2024 as of right now it doesn't seem
there's anything they can do
other than saying we're taking our ball
and going home
meaning fine if it's going to be trump
in the republican party
we'll start a third party and that's
what some former
republican officials have been saying
but the 2024
field i think we're getting ahead of
ourselves
but the 2024 field likely is going to
wait
to see if trump makes an announcement
about running
other than overtly anti-trump
republicans like
if mitt romney were to run for the
nomination in 2024 i don't think he will
i think romney's passed it but
if romney were romney's been an
anti-trump republican for a long time
i think he would just do it but people
like lindsey graham
chris christie i don't know because he
was against trump then he was with him
that was he seems to be against them
the people who are sort of aligned with
trump are going to wait
and take a lead from trump right now the
republican base is donald trump's base
this is just a reality
uh something like 85 percent
of republicans want trump to stay
involved in politics
64 percent of republicans if trump left
and said follow me to my new party
would go with him and right now
you have a situation where the
republican base
is donald trump's base that could change
moderates
are in this position where i'm using the
term moderates carefully by the way
so-called moderate republicans are in a
position where
they don't really know whether 2022
will be a reinforcement of the trumpian
wing or
a rebuke of the trumpian wing and
if indeed the trumpians
win again in 2022 and if indeed donald
trump
chooses to run in 2024 you may see the
so-called moderates
split from the party and that could have
delightfully disastrous consequences for
the republican party we'll see
um i think the focus for now should be
uh starting to think about 2022. david
where do you believe
the ideology of trumpism comes
from is it a discernible historic
ideology this is a really really great
question there's been quite a bit
written about
what exactly is the origin of this
ideology now
aside from the we'll get to the academic
literature if you ask me like how do i
describe the ideology of trumpism
it's really an anti-ideology it's an
ideology not based on policy
it's an ideology based on almost like a
perverted postmodernism
focused on just owning the libs
angering people on the left faux
populism that's really what it's been
about and
there's a lot of academic work about
this that sort of aligns with what i'm
suggesting
um it's kind of like an amalgam
of conspiracies skepticism of government
unless it's your guy and a desire to
exact
revenge and impose punishment on those
who you see
as your political enemies some call it
post-modern conservatism
post-modern conservatism is almost like
it some describe it as a reaction to
what the right sees as bad
identity politics okay post-modern
conservatism where
you talk about alternative facts the
truth can be whatever we want it to be
the reality about what we are told what
is it what is it a lie and what is the
truth
it's all subject to who is the right
trying to embarrass or
insult or own and i think post-modern
conservatism
is a very interesting way to kind of
name the trumpian
ideology mark blythe calls it
global trumpism and matthew goodwin has
used the the phrase
national populism it's like a
nationalistic populism we've talked
about
right-wing nationalism versus left-wing
nationalism i'm sorry
right-wing and left-wing populism where
the rhetoric is often very similar
and people start to think oh i'm a
bernie person but a lot of the rhetoric
sounds similar from trump maybe i'll go
with trump
and then you see the solutions are stop
people from s-hole countries
and china this and china that and antifa
black lives matter they're going to take
your house they're going to take your
kids
you know all this different stuff so
that's another part of it
there's this kind of like my truth world
that is very important to trumpian
ideology
personal experience is what matters
anecdote is what matters
rather than empirical thinking and and
the scientific process
public discourse academia those things
don't matter
in this ideology uh i think that the the
other
part of this that can be tricky is
donald trump appealed to a lot of people
who were previously apolitical
and so when we look at the way
that trumpian ideology and again i get i
understand it's sort of an
anti-ideology but to the extent that
it's an ideology
all of these people stuck to it oh trade
yeah trump will fix trade and we're
being treated unfairly
these were not people really convinced
to switch to that
from something else a lot of these folks
never had a political ideology and trump
brought it down
to the lowest coursest level we've
arguably ever seen
politics which was too boring for a lot
of these people all of a sudden was kind
of interesting
and it was never going to be about
policy or procedure
or science or empiricism these were
folks who never cared about the stuff
before
and they were in it essentially for the
memes and the slogans
and the mottos and that's all it was
ever
going to be for them and now the
question is do they stay involved in
politics or is politics gets quote
boring again do they just bail and that
is as important the absence of an
ideology
is a huge part of the trumpian ideology
and i think we need to understand that
and the question is to whether those
folks remain
involved with trump gone it's still a
question mark we've seen
trump lose some support through
attrition from the republican party over
the last month but he still has a lot of
it
it's just going to be a question we have
to wait to really be able to answer in
full
send me your thoughts and let me know
how how would you characterize trumpian
ideology
we've got a great bonus show for you
today as well the show continues
if you are a member sign up at
joinpackman.com and you can use the code
secret code new code okay listen to this
youtube50 youtube50
new coupon code which you can use at
joinpakman.com
we'll see you on the bonus show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman